学校が終わったので俺はあ
アルフォートのためながら
となる神社に来ていたかもよあのな
5分
こういう外でさ一人で撮るのって本当に勇気がいるんだぜこれも実はあれでもシリーズ
大田も恥ずかしくて
大丈夫で大丈夫胸を張っていこうまっ
今日はなぁ一つ試したいことがあったんですよお前の自転車としているか自転車
これが自転車で見て63の施設も大事電車でございます俺は思ったんだよね電車って
いうのはペダルを漕ぐだけでさあ前に進めたペダルを動かすとチェーンが回転してそれ
に合わせてタイヤも回転するという仕組みになっておりますだから夏電車が動くんだよ
な
多いかなこういう中国わけだこれ分かるようなでなく今回したいのはこちらのローソン
でございます
俺はな1つの矛盾に気づいたわけよチェーンのところにローションをベクターに打っ
たら
チェーンが姉ぬるぬるしちゃって引っかからないんじゃねーかっていう俺の勝手な想像
ですなぜたぶんね
技ないよできるかわかんないけど多分労組北の星部分に栗たくてそれに乗るとちょびっ
とだけ動くとそビットだけ黒糖持てばチェーンだからしっかりしてるからもう
ツルツルすることはないと思う数えてローションもうるう年てるんで
する塗るの絶妙な感覚になって超カ変動詞きの新しい gear タイプの自転車が
できると思いますですねー
やってみたいのやローション塗ってきます
いく上でこれ大丈夫かなぁ
これ大丈夫かなぁおれしらないを一応できました
入って勇気で寝るチェーン出来上がりです入ってきでなんとかヌルヌル自転車ができた
んで
本当にこれがばかりはねちょっとわかんないできると思いたいんだけど
正直無礼な気がすんだよねそう言ってくる若いきまー
ローションをものともせずにチェーンは私の足の重みを受け入れた
軽やかに前へ歩き出したと同ゼリー
私は時が止まったような感覚を覚えたん
[音楽]
自然は美しい秋の色に染まりいっ
わたしの心を魅了した
頑張れ受験生
[音楽]